Hello, everybody!!
My name is Markiplier and welcome to Bear Simulator!
[Beep]
Oh my goodness.
Am I standing on my hind legs?
Oh, this is incredible.
[soft ding of great achievement]
OH!
HURRAY!
I got an achievement!
I am bear!
[Beep]
Ah, the noble bear stalks his prey,
the common pond duck.
Let me get down and crawl towards 'em!
He'll never see me coming!
AHHHH!
I had you!
Don't swaf away!
Aww...
I lost my one chance to make a water fowl friend. :(
[Bing]
ARE YOU A BUNBUN?
BUNBUN GONNA DIEDIE!
HAHA!
[dying squeal]
'Defeated the demoralizing tan rabbit'.
What, did he insult me as he went along?
[Boop]
Am I gonna be implicated for bear murder?
I swear, I didn't know Leo was just trying to film a movie in my woods!
I was just trying to help!
[Doot]
What is this?
'No Trespassing! Top Secret Military Research Compound'
Oh, hello. Hi!
Oh, it's a wolf boy!
He's rabid!
He looks like a corgi!
[Offended growling] Oh god.
AHH!
OH! RUN AWAY!
GERONIMOOO!
Uh oh.
I shouldn't have done that...
[death sounds]
[First video]
This is nothing like Goat Simulator,
This is actually me as a bear!
[Second video]
[quietly] And I received another ball.
[quietly] an odd medical condition,
[still quiet] to have an extra ball.
[Third video]
I... I didn't chose this life!
It was chosen for me!
'I wasn't born a fruit, like you.'
[laughter, fading out]